this is the next line you can see as
well by the way that these two lines are
parallel I mean they're they're 90
percent the same if not more which is a
sort of flag for you when you see a
question they can state the question in
either of these ways they can tell you
hey the parametric equations are these
or they could say a locus is defined
with this point with this set of
coordinates that's the X that's the Y so
that tells you the same amount of
information okay all right now now we
come to this next bit that we're talking
about here tangents and normals right it
says the equation of the tangent the
equation of the normal so we can go
ahead and write these down tangent and
normal write them down for me
okay now when you see something on the
reference sheet what we're trying to say
to you is hey you can use this you can
use this for free which is kind of nice
because this is some work to actually
derive however that doesn't mean that
you can just not know where this come
from comes from let me illustrate this
for you going back on the on the
reference sheet I want you to turn back
to the previous page the previous page
and it's a tuna page and you'll notice
on the left hand column it says what's
the very top thing in the left-hand
column it says differentiation from
first principles okay now what follows
underneath that is a whole bunch of
things about differentiation okay now we
give you all of these laws down the
bottom all these rules and we say yes
you can use this you can just have them
for free don't worry about proving them
however we also say you've got to be
able to do stuff from first principles
and I can guarantee you this is in your
exams you've already done and in the
final HSC exam it's almost a given that
you'll have a 1 or 2 my question that is
a first principles type question so what
does this mean
here's your own pet pickup you
annotating color ok these two equations
here you can quote these without proof
you can quit them without proof but and
here comes the new onsen I never used to
explain this very clearly and so
students got confused but sometimes you
do have to prove them sometimes you do
have to prove them you must be ready to
prove them so I'm trying to draw this
comparison to first principles you learn
first principles and then you learn
rules that work that sort of mean you
don't need first principles anymore
thank God because first principles is
very slow right but that doesn't mean we
say now ignore first principles you
still have to be ready to use first
principles okay and in exactly the same
way yes you can use this you don't have
to prove them every single time but
sometimes you are required to prove them
the question will state it it will just
blank out say prove that the equation of
the tangent to this I'll prove that the
equation of the normal is this and you
say what they said that we could just
quote this like well sometimes you can
and sometimes you can't that's why I'm
highlighting it so I want you to look at
this guy here just this first one I want
you to have a look at the form that it's
in this is a straight line tangents are
straight lines what is the form that
this has been provided to you this is I
can see a gradient right there by the
way the gradient is T that's that's
that's not a coincidence
is it okay the gradient is here what's
this guy this constant on the end is not
just anything in the form of a straight
line that'll be the y-intercept right
okay so it's in point sorry it's in
slope intercept form so where will I
have gotten this from if I were required
to prove this what would I have done
before this line to get to here I did
the gradient sorry I'm breaking my own
rule third color I'm finding the
gradient and what's the other piece of
mission that's gonna go into there it
makes it a tangent right well it's got
the same gradient and it goes through
the same point that's all that's
required it is not hard to find the
equation of the tangent it's just a
little bit of work point gradient
if you go okay the normal looks terrible
it looks much more intimidating but it's
not what would you do differently to
find the equation of the normal one I've
said this anything yet this morning come
on this one's not so hard you can do it
yeah to get to the normal right what
makes a normal or normal okay it still
goes through the same point but the
gradient will not be the same will it it
will be not just the reciprocal it'll be
the negative reciprocal right once you
take that guy do exactly the same thing
you will come up with equation no
problem okay so you can quote this you
can that's why they're there unless they
specifically ask you to prove in which
case you have to be ready to do this
thankfully it's not that terrible people
have to do it all the time
back in the day okay all right now the
last thing that we're going to write
down is the focus of what we're going to
look at today and focus to see what I
did that underneath there it says at and
it's actually not the last thing that's
on the page under this I think we just
won't get to it today it says this now
think think before you have a look at
what's next
look at what they've just said this
tells you something important right here
you're in parameter land right it's that
look there's T's there okay and that's
why subsequently there are teas in your
equation okay but then they get to this
and you're like oh there's no T's
anymore
there's no parameter so this is not
talking about parametric forms anymore
what forms are talking about let's talk
about a Cartesian form
okay so we can still find the equation
of the tangent in the normal without the
parameter it's just a little bit
trickier so let's write these results
down first and then what we're going to
devote our time to today is to actually
proving these results which ends up
being quite ingenious so here's what
we've got
okay by the way just to close this off
right I wanted to review us because we
haven't done this for a little while but
I actually encourage you see what we
just did what we just did I would
encourage you by the end of the agency
course you should be able to do what I
just did what I just walked you through
for the entire reference [ __ ] that's not
because you like you don't get to bring
all of this stuff in but that way like
when I look at the reference sheet I
don't just see this this triggers all of
that in my head okay that's the point of
a memory aid okay and the same thing
should happen for all of the
differentiation stuff and all the trig
stuff in all of the yada yada yada